>>> MORE TROUBLE TOD FOR NEWLY
ELECTED CONGRESSMAN GEORGE
SANTOS.
MOMENTS AGO LEADING REPUBLICANS
BACK HOME, ON LONG ISLAND IN NEW
YORK DEMANDING THE CONGRESSMAN
RESIGN.
>> GEORGE SANTOS' CAMPAIGN LAST
YEAR WAS A CAMPAIGN OF DECEIT,
LIES AND FABRICATION.
HE'S DISGRACED THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES AND WE DO NOT
CONSIDER HIM ONE OF OUR
CONGRESSPEOPLE.
TODAY, ON BEHALF OF THE NASSAU
COUNTY REPUBLICAN COMMITTEE, I'M
CALLING FOR HIS IMMEDIATE
RESIGNATION.
>> HERE IN WASHINGTON, AS YOU
CAN SEE, CONGRESSMAN SANTOS
IMMEDIATELY SWARMED BY REPORTERS
ASKING IF HE WILL QUIT.
HIS ANSWER, QUOTE, I WILL NOT.
ALSO MOMENTS AGO, HOUSE SPEAKER
KEVIN McCARTHY, OTHER TOP
REPUBLICAN LEADERS, NO ANSWER AT
ALL TO THAT QUESTION SHOULD
SANTOS RESIGN.
OUR REPORTERS ARE BACK AT THE
TABLE.
CARL, YOU'VE BEEN AT THIS A LONG
TIME ON CAPITOL HILL.
THIS IS A PROBLEM.
THE CYNIC SAYS KEVIN McCARTHY
DIDN'T DEAL WITH IT BEFORE THE
SPEAKER'S VOTE BECAUSE HE NEEDED
SANTOS' VOTE.
HE'S SPEAKER NOW.
WILL HE DEAL WITH THIS OR WILL
HE TELL HIM TO RESIGN?
THAT'S A RISK OF BEING A
COMPETITIVE DISTRICT.
CONNECTION HAVE A CHANCE TO
NARROW THE REPUBLICAN MAJORITY
EVEN MORE.
>> I WOULD SAY IT WOULD BE A
VERY COMPETITIVE DISTRICT IN A
SPECIAL ELECTION IF HE RESIGNS.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE SAID
THEY'LL HANDLE THIS INTERNALLY.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE HARD
TO SUSTAIN WHEN YOU HAVE THE
REPUBLICANS BACK HOME SAYING
YOU'VE GOT TO GO.
I THINK THEIR WORRY BACK HOME IS
THEY COULD LOSE THIS SEAT
FOREVER IF THIS IS ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE.
ALREADY THE DEMOCRATS ARE TAKING
AIM AT THESE REPUBLICANS WHO
WERE ELECTED IN NEW YORK, GOING
TO FACE A TOUGH TIME IN A
PRESIDENTIAL YEAR.
HE'S CANNON FODDER AS FAR AS THE
DEMOCRATS ARE CONCERNED.
I'D SAY THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
KEEP HIM AROUND BECAUSE IT'S A
GREAT MESSAGE FOR THEM.
>> HE'S A POSTER CHILD FOR THIS
IS TODAY'S MODERN REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
THIS GUY LIED ABOUT JUST ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
LEADER McCARTHY SUPPORTERS
SAYING DO NOT PUT THIS MAN ON
ANY COMMITTEES.
>> I DON'T THINK HE SHOULD BE ON
THAT'S FOR LEADERSHIP TO DECIDE.
>> HE CERTAINLY HASN'T EARNED MY
TRUST.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HIS BACKGROUND,
IF THE KIND OF LIES HE TOLD
DON'T MERIT AN ETHICS
INVESTIGATION, IT REALLY WILL
MAKE EVERYONE SCRATCH THEIR
HEADS.
>> AGAIN, KEVIN McCARTHY IS NOW
THE SPEAKER.
CYNICALLY MAYBE HE NEEDED THAT
VOTE SO HE LET THIS PLAY OUT
THIS FAR.
WILL HE LEAVE?
WILL HE MAKE A DECISION?
AT LEAST ANSWER THE QUESTION,
SORRY, I'M GOING TO POUT HIM ON
COMMITTEES.
>> THE COMMITTEE QUESTION IS AN
ENTERING ONE.
AS RELATES TO MR. SANTOS'
STANDING IN CONGRESS, HE NEEDED
HIS VOTE FOR SPEAKER.
HE MAY NEED IT AGAIN IN THE
FUTURE.
KEVIN McCARTHY WITH THE MOTION
TO VACATE MECHANISM WHERE ANY
ONE PERSON CAN CALL FOR OUSTING.
IT SEEMS WHAT POLICE SAID
YESTERDAY, THEY'RE HANDLING THE
MATTER INTERNALLY.
THE FACT THERE ARE
INVESTIGATIONS IN NEW YORK
STATE, POTENTIAL FEDERAL
INVESTIGATIONS, POW TENL HOUSE
ETHICS COMMITTEE INVESTIGATION,
WE'LL SEE WHERE THAT GOES.
I THINK THAT DOES GIVE KEVIN
McCARTHY AN OUTLET TO SAY WE'RE
GOING TO DEFER TO THESE ON GOING
PROBES.
OBVIOUSLY THOSE CAN LAST FOR A
VERY LONG TIME.
GEORGE SANTOS MAY NOT EVEN BE A
MEMBER BY THE TIME THOSE START
TO GET GOING.
>> MAYBE ONE OF THE EASIEST
THINGS WOULD BE TO LIMIT HIS
MEMBERSHIP ON COMMITTEES,
PARTICULARLY NATIONAL SECURITY
COMMITTEES WHICH PEOPLE SEEM TO
BE WANTING TO KEEP HIM AT ARM'S
LENGTH.
THEY HAVE NO REASON TO TRUST
HIM.
I THINK IF KEVIN McCARTHY COMES
OUT AND ASKS HIM TO RESIGN, IT
WOULD BE A SHOCK IN SO MANY
WAYS.
THE OTHER THING IS WHY WOULD HE
RESIGN?
IF YOU'RE GEORGE SANTOS, HE'S
GOT A DREAM JOB.
HE MAKES A GOOD BIT OF MONEY.
HE ESSENTIALLY WON.
HIS LIES WORKED TO GET HIM THIS
FAR.
IF HE COMES OUT, SANTOS WOULD
LIKELY IGNORE HIM.
>> IT'S HARD TO GET A MEMBER OUT
WHO DOESN'T WANT TO LEAVE.
>> I WAS GOING TO COME BACK TO
THAT.
I WANT TO READ THIS FROM
MINORITY LEADER HAKEEM JEFFRIES,
WHEN WILL HOUSE REPUBLICANS
DECIDE IT'S TIME FOR SANTOS TO
GO?
THEY SEE THIS AS A PIÑATA.
WHEN YOU WROTE ABOUT THE NEW
RULES SMARTLY, KEVIN McCARTHY
CAN SAY THIS IS BEING HANDLED
INTERNALLY.
HE CAN TRY TO STAY -- HAVE THEY
WATERED DOWN THAT PROCESS?
>> THAT'S NOT EVEN SET UP AND
RUNNING.
>> AS WE ALL KNOW, THESE ETHICS
INVESTIGATIONS TAKE FOREVER.
IT EASILY WOULD TAKE THE TWO
FULL YEARS.
IF HE DOESN'T WANT TO GO,
THERE'S NOT MUCH THEY CAN DO TO
GET HIM OUT.
THEY NEEDED THOSE VOTES.
>> THEY NEEDED THOSE VOTES.